j'appelle l'équipe suivante qui est tout
aussi brillante et qui va s'intéresser
alors là à une problématique encore plus
vaste mais qui est pas absente non plus
de ce que devrait être la diplomatie de
la france plus asseoir monsieur
secrétaire général que il monsieur
poniatowski aussi voilà les dames qui
est ce qui nous manque
alors j'avais pas ce cadre au lawrence
eric woerth
car en ligne et philippe cochet philippe
cochet il est là aussi bien alors on va
essayer et on a une heure pour cent donc
là encore je vous appelle mesdames et
messieurs a beaucoup de discipline en
matière de temps de faire un tour
d'horizon des grands problèmes de
gouvernance et de gouvernance
internationale on va pas refaire des
cours d'histoire géo politique enfin il
ya eu une période où il y avait une
gouvernance mondiale par force si j'ose
dire c'était yalta entre 45 et 90 il y
avait deux pilotes dans l'avion et puis
quelques-uns qui essayait de s'infiltrer
entre les deux je pense au général de
gaulle et à notre pays de jouer à la
table des grands en train ordre
bipolaires ainsi sur l'idéologie et les
armes nucléaires ce monde là il est mort
il ya 25 ans et à l'époque j'avais écrit
un livre qui s'appelait nouveau monde
l'ordre de yalta au désordre des nations
on y est en insistant d'ailleurs sur la
démographie sur le terrorisme sur la
montée de l'islam sur les forces
nouvelles du prochain monde aujourd'hui
on est dans un monde sans chef sans
leader on a parlé de monde multipolaire
mais c'est pas à mon équipe là c'est un
monde à polaire il n'y a plus d'eau plus
de chef il ya plus de gendarmes
il suffit de voir ce qui se passe en ce
moment au yémen personnes pilote l'avion
yémen il ya des puissances qui
s'affrontent en syrie en irak
autour du nigeria autour de vos qu'arabe
très compliqué pour les puissances
extérieures de s'asseoir d'imposer un
ordre axel poniatowski qui est mon
collègue député du val d'oise qui va
grand expert de ces questions
à la commission aux affaires étrangères
qu'il a présidée avec moi va nous parler
vivant de la crise du leadership
américain
qu'est-ce qu'il faut attendre de cette
prochaine élection repli par pelé c'est
un dette
le philippe cochet qui est également à
mes collègues députés du lion lui va
regarder la gouvernance économique
internationale y at il ou pas moyen
d'organiser cela puis des autres
participants ici vont garder ou regarder
les grands acteurs qui émergent et y en
a beaucoup on en a cité un certain
nombre ce matin pascal drouhaud qui est
un vieux complice dans cette maison qui
j'ai travaillé de longues années
c'est notre expert sur l'amérique latine
madame gallic terros elle et elle va
s'occuper de nous parler d'eux de la
russie mais pas seulement oui enfin de
la russie si vous voulez me reviendra
j'avais aussi besoin que vous nous
parliez de votre vision plus générale
des acteurs que vous avez analysé dans
vos travaux de consultants lance david
lawrence d'asian au pardon va nous
parler de la chine et eric woerth de
l'inde
donc avec tout ça vous devriez avoir un
tableau à peu près complet des grands
acteurs nouveau des brics et puis des
problèmes de gouvernance
alors peut-être à commencer par les
etats-unis et axel si tu veut bien nous
dire comment tu vois l'évolution de la
politique intérieure et extérieure
américaine
je rappelle à tout le monde que la règle
c'est sept minutes max sinon on tiendra
pas merci beaucoup merci pierre pendant
sept minutes on va faire très rapide je
pense que c'est pas inutile de rappeler
ce que tu viens de dire
tu parlais depuis la période 1945 1990
on est dans la période bipolaire avec
les deux mondes le monde le monde libre
le monde le monde communiste et
finalement avec cette menace permanente
de l'armada de l'arme atomique
on est dans une période qui finalement
est assez stable effondrement de l'urss
en 1981 9
on rentre dans un monde qui est le monde
unipolaire dominé par les américains et
face à l'émergence à ski et le début de
l'émergence de l'islamisme radical qui
finalement aura démarré disons plutôt
partir de 1979 avec l'arrivée au pouvoir
de cabinet en iran et puis surtout avec
exactement au même moment l'invasion de
l'afghanistan par le par la russie
période qui aura duré une dizaine
d'années et qui aura permis finalement
cette émergence de ceux de ce monde
radical
et puis depuis 2010 finalement et depuis
2010 et l'émergence du et le printemps
arabe et le bourbier syrien on est dans
un monde qui est totalement multipolaire
sans véritable gouvernance mondiale avec
un début avec des objectifs qui sont
différents et pour chacune et des
grandes puissances ou des grands ou des
grands pôles et finalement une situation
qui n'est pas coordonnée et là on ne
parle plus des mes références du
mouvement radical islamiste mais de
l'apparition de groupes et de puissance
radical qui dans certains cas se sont
substitués aux états je parlais de ce
qui a été dit tout à l'heure des
talibans d'état islamique d'al qaïda de
elle ne sera de boko haram
ils sont de véritables puissances
quasiment étatiques alors dans cette
situation qu'elle est
on a assisté finalement depuis
l'élection d'obama en 2008 un repli
américain de désengagement américain
désengagement d'afghanistan qui s'est
plus ou moins bien passé des engagements
également de l'irak qui a été qui a été
compliqué et puis finalement à la fin de
ceux de ce mandat d'obama avec un
réengagement américain ce sont les
frappes aériennes à la fois en irak et
en syrie
c'est l'envoi de forces spéciales
maintenant sur le terrain d'ailleurs
nous aussi français ont fait on commence
à faire la même chose en particulier en
libye et obama s'est aperçu que
probablement ce repli a été trop rapide
trop profond et qu' il ne pouvait pas se
maintenir sans son que les etats unis
eux mêmes se se trouve menacée est très
intéressant que tu tiennes ce débat
finalement cette conférence asthme en ce
moment c'est à dire quelques jours après
orlando
parce que je pense que or leur dos
marquera une étape importante dans la
politique américaine
même si on n'a pas encore complètement
décoder ce qui s'est passé la semaine
dernière
il ya tout de même pour la première fois
depuis 2001 bien sûr cet effondrement
des tours de manhattan
mais il ya deux depuis 2001 la première
fois la réapparition de la d'une
présence terroriste aux etats unis dont
les américains devront tenir compte
alors très rares et plus notre qu'est ce
qui peut se passer finalement avec les
deux nouveaux candidats aux
présidentielles américaines
si cette hillary clinton qui est élu et
je pense que ce sera hillary clinton
personnellement qui sera élu je le pense
d'ailleurs tout simplement parce que l
le lait totalement majoritaire dans les
minorités minorité hispanique minorité
afro-américaine qui aujourd'hui font pas
pratiquement la moitié de la population
américaine et jeux sont deux électorats
dans lequel il
hillary clinton offre approchant les 80
pour cent pour cent des boîtes et je
pense que c'est la raison et je pense
est ce que c'est ce qui lui permettra de
gagner les élections américaines
si ces gars et clinton je pense qu'on
assistera à peu près à la poursuite de
la politique américaine actuelle
c'est-à-dire avec petit à petit un
réengagement américain sur les dans les
endroits dans les lieux où se constitue
l'une des principales menaces avait
quelque chose de plus coordonnée en
particulier avec les âmes
avec les amériques avec les européens et
j'espère également avec les russes elle
a bien évidemment le la situation est
plus compliquée si c'est donald trump
qui est élu je crains que nous
assistions dans un premier temps comme
ça s'est souvent produit après
l'élection d'un président américain sans
aucune expérience à une période de
flottement et voir à une période de
bêtise ou des erreurs pourront être
commis c'est à dire qu'il appliquera ce
qu'il est en train de déclarer et
évidemment ça conduira à une période qui
sera une période déstabiliser tra
déstabilisatrices et les six élus
tiennent à coeur il ne pourra pas ne pas
se ressaisir par la suite donc voilà
très rapidement envisagé je crois que
c'est ce qu'on peut dire à ce stade
c'est tout ça n'est pas très n'est pas
très original mais je crois que ce sont
les principales lignes auquel il faut
s'attendre
merci beaucoup axel pour cette analyse
je crois très juste je pense qu'il
arrive perdre parce qu'elle est détester
cordialement mais ce que tu dis sur la
sur l'arithmétique des minorités et
juste
quant aux quant aux extrêmes de tram
qu'il peut appliquer là aussi tu as
raison on a vu à quoi pouvait mener bush
au moment d'une grande catastrophe comme
11 septembre qu'on paye toujours 25 ans
après donc l'amérique en retrait certes
mais toujours extraordinairement pesante
sur le système international
je pense qu'il serait pas mauvais à ce
stade de passer de dire un mot de la
russie madame mengue acté route pour
voir si nous avons qu est ce qui reste
du système bipolaire bien alors sept
minutes c'est vraiment une gageur sur la
russie surtout si vous voulez que je
parle d'autre chose
bon j'ai six points j'ai choisi six
points pour essayer de retracer un peu
ce qui s'est passé où on en est alors
l'implosion de lure 191 bien sûr a
inauguré une décennie 90 qui a été une
décennie de descente aux enfers pour la
russie c'est ce qu'il faut comprendre
d'un affaiblissement tous azimuts
affaiblissement un terme bien sûr
paupérisation de la population sans
précédent destruction de la puissance
publique pillage économique
affaiblissement externe avec
l'élargissement double de l'ue et de
l'otan
jusqu'aux frontières russes qui est
quand même a été très mal ressenti repli
diplomatique et militaire lourd donc
plus de glacis sécuritaire pour les
russes et au même moment dans cet art
qui se recompose est l'occident au lieu
de conserver une place à la russie en
fonction de son passé de ce qu'elle
avait été de sa densité finalement à
considérer que cet affaiblissement tous
azimuts signifiait la dissolution de la
nation russe elle même est un
renoncement définitif à la puissance
était une très lourde erreur mais ce fut
la fameuse époque de la fin de
l'histoire du rêve éveillé de duvet
victis comme on dîne mort au vaincu donc
l'occident non seulement n'a pas eu le
triomphe modeste mais a eu la main très
lourde vis-à-vis des russes sur tout un
tas de sujets conséquence le
développement d'un sentiment
d'humiliation d'injustice d'un
encerclement qui n'est pas cosmétiques
qui est profond ce qu'on appelle le
complexe obsidionale russe
ce n'est pas un fantasme c'est un fait
politique à part entière dans les
conséquences sont très lourdes parce que
les perceptions collective les affects
en politique et notamment en politique
étrangère sont défaits à part entière et
c'est sur ce terreau psychologique que
vladimir poutine a construit a conduit
la russie finalement de cet abaissement
à une forme de renaissance
il n'y a pas simplement il s'est pas
simplement appuyé sur le ressentiment
populaire
russes qui étaient lourds fin des années
90 il a fait le pari que le nouvel ordre
mondial
l'amérique hyper puissante et xena
deviendrait pas et qu'on aurait un monde
multipolaire et on peut dire
qu'aujourd'hui il a gagné ce pari
notre table ronde en est la preuve
parallèlement en europe
tous nos fantasmes post moderne post
nationaux prenaient le vent l'économisme
bea
le rejet de l'histoire des appartenances
des frontières tout ça lui a donné entre
guillemets du grain à moudre
par contraste fragmentation
communautariste enfin voilà on connaît
tous sa déconstruction de l'identité des
peuples européens grande vulnérabilité
d'un ensemble européen grandissante
crispations identitaires des peuples bon
quels sont les déterminants de la
puissance russe actuelle et ses
ambitions
un chef charismatique tout sauf normale
vous en conviendrez qui veut être
respecté et craint de tous beaucoup plus
qu aimer un état autoritaire partial
mais très protecteur qui offre aux
citoyens une appartenance à une réalité
politique forte
multi séculaire qui assume sa différence
un état qui inscrit donc la russie
moderne dans une continuité historique
et ça c'est très important
une synthèse que certains trouvent
grandiloquente ou grandioses selon qu'il
ya des zones d'ombré qu'il ya des mais
qui assume tout qu'ils assument l'ombre
la lumière
y a qu'à voir la cérémonie d'ouverture
des jeux de sotchi pour se rendre compte
de cette synthèse du site une synthèse
agissante et qui a l'appui du peuple un
discours internationale claire qui est
fondée sur un régime de croisière à ses
fins marquée par le réalisme le
légalisme l'opportunisme et puis des
lignes rouges qu'il ne faut pas franchir
parce qu'à ce moment là l'usagé de la
force est totalement assumée envisagée
est mise en oeuvre donc une démocratie
dite qui se dit souren qui fait pâlir
d'envié évidemment secrètement beaucoup
de gens parce que finalement c'est une
l'alliage assez efficace de l'exaltation
de la patrie de contrôle social et
politique ferme et de libéralisme
économique tempéré je reviens de moscou
je peux vous dire qu'on y sent pas du
tout les sanctions on y sent en revanche
la puissance
on y sent l'autorité on y sent le mépris
souverain pour le rejet du reste du
monde
on y sent la détermination la force
tranquille enfin bref certain nombre de
choses qui dans d'autres parties du
monde manque donc sa flotte dans l'air
ça sature l'air même d'accord moscou
n'est pas la russie mais paris n'est pas
la france n'est pas l'amérique donc
c'est quand même assez significatif
quelles sont les ambitions russes
bien sûr retrouver son rang gérer le
monde en duo avec washington se
rapprocher de l'europe
encore et toujours même si il ya eu
beaucoup davani subi et beaucoup d'
affront à laver lutter contre la
déstabilisation islamistes ou en wide
partout dans le monde
préserver ses intérêts son influence
notamment énergétique au moyen orient
face à l'iran face à l'arabie saoudite
maîtrise et l'intégration régionale de
l'eurasie surtout contre la chine face à
la chine bien sûr c'est pour faire
pendant à l'europe mais c'est surtout
pour faire pendant à la chine et pour
essayer de maîtriser la puissance
montante de la chine qui à mon avis du
point de vue de moscou est quand même la
menace la plus massive et la plus proche
l'état du monde
on en a parlé je reviendrai pas dessus
lorient à feu et à sang
donc la montée de la chine le
déplacement stratégique américain vers
l'asie qui démonétise évidemment
l'europe au plan stratégique la
comprimer est en train de nous faire
disparaître si on met nos faiblesses
propres
en parallèle nous faire disparaître de
la carte du monde geopolitics quand même
assez ennuyeux or on a avec la russie un
pays qui depuis pierre le grand et même
avant schisme n'a jamais cessé de se
considérer comme faisant pleinement
partie de l'europe et même de l'occident
on a une communauté culturelle enfin bon
tout ça tout le monde le sait politique
un terreau chrétien commun qui sont tout
simplement incontestable
les annuaires poutine depuis qu'il est
arrivé au pouvoir en 99 et d'ailleurs
fait un nombre considérable d'appel du
pied en vain à l'union européenne pour
un rapprochement économique et
stratégique évidemment l'élargissement
de l'union européenne l'a pas beaucoup
aidé et au moyen orient il n'a fait
finalement que s'engouffrer dans le
double vie de notre ouvert par notre
notre cynisme et notre angélisme à la
fois il a rebattu les cartes on ne
pourra plus compter sans lui maintenant
dans cette zone comme l'a très bien dit
fabrice balanche et il a fait aussi
tomber les masques de la politique
occidentale qui est pour le moins
équivoque dans cette région alors que
faire pour moi il faut faire de la
realpolitik
enfin il faut en finir avec le
dogmatisme et l'idéalisme en politique
étrangère ça ne marche tout simplement
pas faut arrêter de donner des leçons il
faut coller au réel il faut se
réconcilier avec lui il faut redéfinir
complètement notre politique étrangère
de fond en comble enfin ou presque
peut-être certaines choses très bonne et
je pense que la realpolitik est
infiniment plus humaine et protectrice
des peuples paradoxalement que
l'idéalisme crispé qui nourrit l'ennemi
en fait tout simplement bon combien de
morts en syrie pour avoir voulu les
gommer ce régime
combien de temps perdu encore à vouloir
le faire tomber
et les des rebelles soit disant modérés
qui en fait ne rêve que de le dépecer
dans le sens de toute manière moscou ne
nous laissera pas faire pas par
angélisme pas par bonté d'âme pour les
syriens mais pour préserver ses intérêts
régionaux
là aussi nous avons franchi une ligne
rouge qui est désormais très sanglantes
moscou a une grande capacité de nuisance
mais aussi d' influence positive sur de
nombreux foyers de crise ans j'ai pas
fini c'est non parce que c'est important
c'est tellement convaincant c'est un
c'est un état multiethnique
c'est un certain état multiconfessionnel
avec une intégration réussie
décomplexés quand même de 20 millions de
musulmans 11% de la population un peu
plus elle comprend par définition dont
beaucoup mieux le moyen-orient que nous
les états voilà multiconfessionnel
multiethnique nous avons tous cherché à
abattre et à déconstruire on voit où on
en est elle s'est donc lutter contre
l'islamisme et surtout elle n'ose lutter
contre l'islamisme
donc je pense qu'il faut cesser
d'alimenter la prophétie auto
réalisatrice d'un prétendu ennemi russe
quand on voit ce qui se passe à l'otan
en ce moment c'est assez inquiétant est
évidemment certains jeunes pays membres
de l'alliance ou de l'union européenne
qui sont traumatisés par leur histoire
propre avec la russie pousse à cela mais
ce n'est pas l'intérêt de l'europe
il s'agit donc pas d'être pro russe
d'être poutine au lard trou je ne sais
quoi mais il s'agit de comprendre de
respecter et de regarder la réalité
stratégique du monde est de savoir où on
veut nous français et européens être
donc il faut revoir notre alliance
privilégiée et naturelle avec l'amérique
il s'agit pas de la revoir sur le fond
bien sûr mais de cesser de la confondre
avec une allégeance pur et dur parce que
nous avons des intérêts sécuritaires et
économiques propres
nous avons nos menaces propres nous
subissons une porosité spécifique avec
tous les foyers de crise dont on a parlé
donc on doit être quand même autre chose
qu'une zone tampon entre washington et
moscou
or ce qui est temps c'est ce qui est en
train de se faire que ce soit en ukraine
que ce soit
au moyen-orient on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui c'est le duo c'est ce que
recherche moscou c'est finalement voilà
la solution en syrie n'arrivera que si
washington et moscou s'entendre l'autre
péril c'est le rapprochement qui
pourrait bien arriver qui est en train
de se faire par dépit de la part de la
russie entre la russie et la chine
avec l'intégration de l'eurasie avec la
nouvelle route de la soie avec la
communauté économique eurasiatique des
russes et si on ne s'en sert pas dans ce
processus si on n'arrive pas à faire une
coopération dans ce domaine et y
associer l'europe
on va se retrouver tout simplement avec
un ensemble considérable énorme à nos
portes qui va se retourner contre nous à
un moment donné voilà en conclusion je
pense qu'il faut simplement remettre
l'europe au coeur du monde et la france
au coeur de l'europe comme puissances
médiatrices centrale parce que c'est là
notre rôle c'est le rôle qu'on avait
pendant la guerre froide et on est quand
même on doit être autre chose qu'une
cible molle pour le terrorisme pour le
hooliganisme
il faut donc reprendre à mon avis notre
rôle de courroie de transmission entre
est et ouest qui nous a été
progressivement ravi par nos amis
allemands à partir de la réunification
qui eux jouent très habilement sur les
deux tableaux puisqu'ils sont à la fois
en lien constant avec washington est en
dialogue profond avec moscou on a tout
intérêt à faire avancer l'europe vers
l'asie aussi puisqu'il ya ce shift
stratégique de l'amérique mais avec la
russie qui doit devenir le pôle
asiatique de cette nouvelle europe des
nations dirait ton de l'atlantique à
l'oural
là encore je pense que la france a tout
pour être un modèle et un catalyseur
ça sera compliqué parce que l'intérêt
américain n'est pas forcément de nous
aider à devenir nous européens bloquent
politiquement puissant il faut donc
réinventer tout notre équilibre de
défense
il faut associer la russie à certains
enjeux sécuritaires que nous partageons
avec elle une question de survie pour
l'europe survie géo stratégiques et
politiques
voilà il ya encore tout à faire avec la
russie c'est juste à nous de le vouloir
je vous remercie
merci beaucoup
madame dialecte et rose pour une lecture
lecture très juste très juste ce que
merci pour votre commentaire monsieur
merci beaucoup je disais la même chose
donc on est 2e au moins deux ont mis
d'accord fondamentalement d'accord pour
féliciter madame galec terros vraiment
je pense que vous avez fait une analyse
très fine de ce que vivent et pensent
terrus depuis la fin de la guerre froide
vous avez sans doute réveillé dans cette
famille politique ici un goût de
l'autorité de l'efficacité qui sera
probablement au menu ce soir delà du
dîner entre nicolas sarkozy et vladimir
poutine puisqu'ils vont dîner ce soir et
à saint pétersbourg
non mais quelques-uns à faire le voyage
avec lui cet après midi non je pense que
c'est très bien vu je voulais vous
remercier de votre analyse
je pense qu'on a fait tout faux depuis
hollande je dirais en fin de matinée
dont le refus de parler et de bâtir une
confiance avec ce voisin qui est
pourtant incontournable et avec lequel
nous partageons l'essentiel des intérêts
stratégiques c'est ma conviction
profonde comme vous et je pense que ce
dialogue entre la lecture américaine
lecture russe doit être fort
d'enseignement pour nous donc on
continue le tour d'horizon
après les etats-unis la russie madame
diallo dit nos hameaux de la chine et on
terminera par l'amérique latine puis par
une vision un peu plus économique de
notre ami philippe cochet tout à l'heure
madame diane où vous avez la parole
après rien notre mère notre maître à
tous eric qui va parler de l'inde juste
après leur onzième après la russie la
chine faut-il avoir peur ou pas de la
chine
comment travailler avec pékin c'est
quand même la deuxième puissance
économique mondiale la première si on
parle en en parité de pouvoir d'achat
donc c'est une question qui est
importante
je commencerai mon propos par trois
chiffres le premier en 2000 la chine
produisait 15% de l'acier mondial
je sais pas si vous savez combien c'est
aujourd'hui en 2016 aujourd'hui c'est 50
% deuxième chiffre 1 les émissions de
co2 la chine aujourd'hui représentent 30
% des émissions mondiales de co2 c'est à
dire que si on veut faire quelque chose
dans la réduction et dans
l'environnement il faut absolument que
la chine y participent sinon ça ne
servira à rien et le troisième chiffres
que je voudrais citer c'est le nombre
d'entreprises que la chine d'entreprises
européennes que la fina racheter et bale
en a racheté autant au premier semestre
2016 que sur toute l'année 2015
donc vous voyez que la chine est un
partenaire qui est absolument
incontournable aujourd'hui c'est un
interlocuteur diplomatiques politiques
essentielles on vient de le voir avec la
russie
d'ailleurs les russes et les chinois se
regardent en chiens de faïence caroline
l'a dit le v10 vostok aujourd'hui et
chinois ça les chinois ont complètement
sont complètement sur le territoire
sibérien en tout cas à leurs frontières
ils sont aussi importants caroline la
cité sur les nouvelles routes de la soie
elles sont aussi bien terrestres que
maritimes
ils sont entrés à l' omc en 2001 et ils
sont dans le g20 n'a parlé du g7 du g8
on devrait aussi parler du g20 qui a été
créée en 2008 par paire notre président
la chine c'est également un marché
gigantesque la chine c'est une classe
moyenne de 109 millions d'habitants
c'est plus important que la classe
moyenne américaine qui l a tiré la
croissance économique ces dernières
années la chine on la connaît tous aussi
comme un fournisseur de produits à bon
marché qui ne connaît pas le made in
china et crise où tous les produits que
l'on que l'on achète
et puis
la chine est un partenaire industriel
qui pour nous aujourd'hui est
indispensable on a été chercher les
chinois de dong feng pour ne pas perdre
psa et on a une alliance entre edf et
les nucléaire chinois pour construire le
p r que ce soit en chine à taishan ou en
angleterre avec les potes donc on voit
bien que la chine est un hôtel au cutter
qui est indispensable qui est
incontournable mais c'est un
interlocuteur difficile c'est un
interlocuteur d'abord qui a un régime
politique très autoritaire donc pas
toujours facile de discuter avec puis
surtout c'est un concurrent économique
qui est perturbateur voir déloyale
d'abord ils ont une force de frappe qui
est impressionnante ils ont un dynamisme
commercial important incontestable avec
l'apparition de grandes entreprises
mondiales
fosun qui a racheté le club méditerranée
d'une zhang qui est en train de monter
au capital d'accor hôtels d'accor hôtel
vous avez alibaba la première entreprise
internet et vous avez promis que l'on
connaît pas ici mais qui en chine est
beaucoup plus important que apple ou
autres dans les portables
il y à des surcapacités de production
qui faussent le marché mondial je vous
en ai parlé en introduction avec l'acier
mais on peut aussi parler de tout ce qui
est panneaux solaires les chinois ont
investi le marché au fait dramatiquement
chuté les prix de tous qui est panneaux
solaires ont tué toute la concurrence
donc aujourd'hui si vous voulez un
panneau solaire ya plus que du finnois
donc les prix évidemment vont pas tarder
à remonter
et puis vous avez la difficulté de vous
installer quand vous êtes une entreprise
étrangère en chine je vous ai dit que
les chinois acheté beaucoup en europe
mais quand une entreprise s'installer en
chine elle est obligée de faire une
alliance qui est minoritaire avec un
partenaire local qui est en général une
entreprise publique donc derrière vous
avez le gouvernement chinois
donc tout ça nous amène à la question de
l'octroi du statut d'économie de marché
qui nous occupe alors récemment mais
depuis quelques temps d'ailleurs
notamment avec anne marie idrac
on avait écrit un article pour tirer la
sonnette d'alarmé ya quelques années
donc faut-il octroyés ou pas le statut
d'économie de marché à la chine à l'om
c'est ben écoutez en s'y était engagé
donc ça a été une question qui va être
compliqué mais ça va désarmer
commercialement l'union européenne la
chine c'est également un créancier un
créancier mondial la chine a des
réserves monétaires de 3000 milliards de
dollars je sais pas si vous pouvez vous
imaginer ce que ça peut donner
et puis elle crée ses propres
instruments financiers
caroline le disait la russie regarde
vers la chine parce que la chine lui
fait peur mais la chine est en train de
court circuiter le système international
dead
elle a créé sa propre banque
d'investissement dans les
infrastructures pour l'asie parce que la
banque asiatique de développement qui
est une émanation de la banque mondiale
il vint ça lui plaît pas elle accroît à
là créer son propre fonds pour la route
de la soie également pour financer les
investissements
et puis la chine également devient une
menace militaire on parlait des budgets
de défense
tout à leur budget de la défense chinois
il augmente de 10% par an est
aujourd'hui c'est le deuxième budget
mondial après les états unis la chine
on en entend souvent parler elle a des
revendications en mer deux films sur des
îlots qu'elle est en train de
militariser et puis et c'est une grande
première dans toute l'histoire de la
chine
la chine est en train de se projeter à
l'extérieur pour la première fois elle
s'installe à djibouti où il est en train
de monter une base militaire terrestre
pour défendre ses intérêts on en a parlé
tout à l'heure ses intérêts économiques
en afrique est également ses
ressortissants qui sont en afrique
alors d'ici quelques décennies la chine
pourra être le challenger des états unis
et un adversaire potentiel et donc par
rapport à ce défi que nous présente les
films qu'elles peuvent être nos
propositions moi j'en citerai 4 d'abord
il faut intégrer pleinement la chine
dans la gouvernance mondiale notamment
au sein du g20 qui est à réactiver
pour qu'elle assume ses nouvelles
responsabilités notamment en matière de
climat et en matière de monnaies si on
n'a pas le temps d'en parler mais la
monnaie chinoise est également un grand
perturbateur des marchés monétaires
internationaux
il faut défendre notre politique
commerciale européenne pour qu'on soit
moins naïfs pour qu'on soit plus
offensif
refuser le statut d'économie de marché
sauve et l'acier européen puisque c'est
quand même un élément majeur de notre
souveraineté créer un conseil de
sécurité économique commercial européen
pour défendre nos intérêts aussi bien
offensif où est ce qu'on va dans quel
domaine mais aussi défensif
protéger nos entreprises et surtout nos
jeunes pousses innovantes développer les
coopérations industrielles
j'en ai parlé sur le nucléaire et on en
a parlé tout à l'heure sur l'afrique sur
l'urbanisation
nous avons en france la chance d'avoir
des entreprises qui excellent dans tout
ce qui touche à l'urbanisation que ce
soit l'eau l'énergie les déchets les
transports
tout ça ce sont des savoir faire qui
sont à valoriser notamment en afrique
et puis dernièrement et je parle sous le
contrôle de nos ambassadeurs redéployer
notre réseau diplomatique vers les pays
émergents d'afrique et d'asie pour
regagner les parts de marché on en
parlait tout à l'heure ne pas laisser la
chine nous supplanter or notre réseau
aujourd'hui il est insuffisamment adapté
à tous ces enjeux nouveaux globo merci
je sais pas si vous avez remarqué là la
qualité des dames à cette tribune ce
matin
oui les applaudir son brillantissime
laurence est également secrétaire
général de notre mouvement et vous voyez
qu'il ya quand même des talents dans la
jeune génération qui font plaisir à voir
sur sur la chine suit motorisé avant que
je passe à l'inde avec eric
je crois que le problème de fond qui est
devant nous et j'ai à dire c'est pour
synthétiser ce que laurence viennent
nous dire si au fond est-ce que c'est un
un contributeur à la stabilité mondiale
demain où c'est un prédateur
chaque question de fond les salles sujet
et comment est-ce qu'on amène la chine à
devenir contributeur plutôt que
prédateur
hélas la fin de la naïveté je croyais
est en effet de saison il faudrait qu'à
l'automme et des on y travaille avec un
certain deux collègues nous présenterons
résolution nous les républicains sur le
statut d'économie de marché de la chine
parce que trop c'est trop
la même façon qu'il faut se battre
contre l'imperium américain en matière
juridique ce que nous avons fait c'est
ce que j'ai fait beaucoup y compris dans
la loi sapin de la même façon s'agissant
de la chine
il faut dire non à au grand n'importe
quoi qui est faite de rouleaux
compresseurs économique sans réciprocité
l'ancien musicaux mer 6 heures que je
suis peux vous dire une entreprise
française qui arrive en chine doit non
seulement prouver une joint-venture mais
doit doit créer en chine un système de
recherche et développement et donner à
l'avance à la chine
la propriété de tous les brevets qui
seront trouvées en chine
troisièmement sachez qu'il y ait en
chine
believe it or not un ministère de la
contrefaçon
j'ai passé des moments inoubliables dans
ma vie à discuter de avec le ministre de
la contrefaçon notamment du petit
crocodile lacoste
il faut que vous sachiez que la cour
suprême chinoise après des 10
de d'année et de procédure dans
différentes cures chinoise à travers
tout le pays
la cour suprême chinoise il y a deux ans
a décrété que le crocodile avec la q1
verser ses mains qui vers la gauche et
un dans la droite
la cour suprême a dit ceci étant donné
l'ampleur de la contrefaçon en chine
le peuple chinois sait quel est le vrai
crocodiles du pas vrai et que donc tous
les tous les tous les arrêts qui avait
invalidé la gombe pénaliser la
contrefaçon été annulée par la cour
suprême chinoise
donc là encore faut peut-être descendre
du monde des bisounours
et quand on est en charge d'un pays qui
devraient être sérieux comme la france
demandé un minimum de droit c'est-à-dire
la réciprocité
merci laurence pour cette vision là
encore très juste vous pouvez
l'applaudir à nouveau ce hachis bon
alors maintenant on passe au passo
gandhi des républicains c'est à dire
eric woerth qui avec son style épuré
habituelle et son intelligence à nous
parler de ce très très grand pays très
très grand qui s'appelle l'inde et qui
va être un des grands rivaux de la chine
dans les prochaines années qui passent
en importance pour nous merci eric tu as
contribué
merci pierre moi j'ai pas du tout
l'homme est tellement le niveau d
expertise de nos précédents orateurs et
oratrice mais je voudrais vous dire un
mot sur sur l'inde
je suis président du groupe d'amitié à
l'assemblée nationale c'est un pays que
je suis depuis longtemps j'avais dit
j'ai un rapport et quelques années sur
la place de de l'inde
en tout cas les relations entre l'inde
et la france et axel poniatowski le
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères avait demandé de le faire je
le remercie encore c'est la plus grande
démocratie du monde
tout le monde le dit tout le monde le
pense et c'est vrai mais c'est une
démocratie très compliqué les guides
touristiques en général disent payer
plusieurs facettes du ca pour à peu près
tout on dit beaucoup pour l'un et pour
l'autre c'est assez vrai
pays continent tout à fait gigantesque
ce sera le premier pays du monde dans
quelques années dans l'est dans une
dizaine d'années il sera plus peuplé que
la chine il ya un nouveau premier
ministre
narendra modi que nous sommes allés
rencontrer il y a quelques semaines avec
nicolas sarkozy qu'une intense activité
internationale
ce soir il dîne avec vladimir poutine
donc c'est très très importante s'ouvrir
au monde il pas possible de faire un
projet ou porter une vision du pays sans
une ouverture totale au monde et ce
monsieur maudit est un homme
considérable il pilote l'avenir de plus
d'un milliard d'indiens et surtout il
est là pour essayer d'assurer à la fois
la paix dans ce ce pays est extrêmement
contrastées très pacifique est très
violent à la fois à gérer des relations
internationales elle même très très
complexe mais aussi en assurer un modèle
de développement qui est un tout petit
peu de mal à se trouver
30 % des indiens n'ont pas d'électricité
aujourd'hui une grande partie des
indiens sont encore malheureusement
analphabètes du système d'éducation est
loin d'être un système parfait le
système d'éducation et d'enseignement
supérieur est un système remarquable
mais avant l'enseignement supérieur les
jeunes indiens et notamment ceux issus
de catégories pauvres et de ce dieu sait
qu'ils sont nombreux ne bénéficie pas du
service qu'ils devraient avoir c'est
donc une priorité majeure et en même
temps ce sera un des pays qui comptera
le plus bas on dit depuis longtemps
depuis très longtemps et on a du mal à
voir l'inde émerger contrairement c'est
un pays très très différent de la de la
russie est un pays très très différent
de la de la chine
et pourtant il posera considérablement
dans les années et dans les décennies
qui viennent
et moi je voudrais plaidé pour que nous
renforcions de façon réelle de façon
totale de façon concrète notre
partenariat stratégique avec l'inde
aujourd'hui nos relations avec la russie
qui vont qu'à 1 k mais ces relations
sont anciennes
et nos relations avec la chine qui sont
au fond à mettre souvent au premier plan
considère que les mutants de fascination
fascination répulsion certainement mais
une fascination pour la chine
et tout ça mais un peu derrière le
paravent ce que nous devrions faire avec
l'inde et nous devons absolument
relancer nos relations avec l'inde
alors nous avons des relations
spectaculaire avec l'inde dans le
domaine économique
on est en train de vendre des rafale pas
autant qu'on pensait blanc fait en tout
cas les engagements sont aujourd'hui
quasiment définitivement pris en hâte ce
qui est définitif mais du temps mais ce
temps est en train de payer tant mieux
bravo à ceux qui ont négocié cela depuis
des années des années nous avons aussi
la capacité de vendre notre industrie
nucléaire il n'y aura des ep air en inde
l'inde est un pays très très carbone et
une bonne partie de son énergie provient
du du charbon il faut absolument que
l'inde devienne une puissance nucléaire
civile c'est le cas avec les yeux pers
il ya déjà des centrales nucléaires en
ab elle va passer à un stade supérieur
et puis il faut pas oublier non plus et
moins connues que une entreprise comme
cap gemini qui est une entreprise de
consulting international mais française
capgemini à 90000 personnes en inde
90000 personnes donc on est un grand
employeur
la plupart des groupes du cac 40 y sont
et tente d'y faire leur travail dans des
conditions juridiques souvent absolument
impossible bon tout ça est très
spectaculaire les rafales le nucléaire
capgemini
mais en même temps on voit bien que
d'autres pays les allemands par exemple
sont tout à fait capables d'avoir des
relations économiques moins
spectaculaire moins brillante peut-être
enfin tellement plus solide est
tellement plus rémunératrices et nous
devons nous installer dans la durée en
inde ce qui n'est pas tout à fait le cas
aujourd'hui et cette ses relations entre
la france et l'inde
elles sont assez ancien on les oublie on
a l'impression que la colonisation
anglaise
elle fait en sorte que l'inde et
l'angleterre c'est un peu encore la même
chose pas du tout il ya des relations d'
ambiguïté comme toujours avec les
anciennes puissances coloniales
on connaît cela avec l'afrique donc il
ya une relation ambigüe
klein le français est la deuxième langue
enseignée après l'anglais en est donc à
une envie de france en inde et on doit
pouvoir l'exploiter
je ne sais pas si vous savez mais à des
principaux industriels groupe industriel
indien il y en a beaucoup mais c'est
tata bien connue des français tat est né
en france et il est enterré le fondateur
du groupe tata et il est enterré au père
lachaise
je ne sais pas si on peut construire
l'avenir d'une politique économique à
partir du père lachaise peut-être pas
enfin en tout cas nous avons des racines
profondes avec ce pays et on doit passer
d'une logique de conquête comme si
c'était un marché émergent à une vraie
logique de partenariat économique mais
on doit élargir nos champs d'activité et
tant mieux
nos champs d'expertisé sont ceux dont
l'inde a besoin
je pense à plusieurs sujets je pense
notamment au sujet de l'agroalimentaire
ya des problèmes majeurs de production
et des problèmes majeurs d'agriculture
on le voit encore en ce moment avec la
la mousson on voit que l'inde a besoin
d'être en autosuffisance et c'est pas le
cas et on aime l'inde a besoin
logistique agroalimentaire simplement
avoir des entrepôts frigorifié à faire
en sorte que les relais les récoltes ne
se perdent pas et cette logistique
agroalimentaire nous sommes capables de
la deûle à fournir et de les y aider
c'est vrai dans le domaine des services
urbains on vous construit des métros ont
construit aller à bombay vous verrez
c'est totalement impossible de se
déplacer
on voit bien que la mobilité est un
quelque chose de très important les
français sont très forts évidemment dans
le domaine de la mobilité
il ya déjà des choses qui ont été faites
évidemment mais il faut aller beaucoup
plus loin et que cela je pense aussi au
spatial et à la recherche
il y a en inde des chercheurs tout à
fait remarquable des entreprises tout à
fait remarquable c'est peu connu mais la
france doit se développer avec l'inde
dans le domaine du spatial je pense aux
télécoms
je pense aussi à la gestion de
l'environnement la distribution de l'eau
en inde est un sujet absolument majeur
et nous devons y faire ce que nous avons
à faire pia notre point que je voulais
évoquer c'est tout le problème de
l'éducation je l'évoqué pour
l'enseignement primaire et secondaire
qui doit être développé les menacer la
question et le problème réellement des
indiens mais dans le domaine de
l'éducation supérieure
les indiens sont en relation avec les
american façon très forte
les indiens dispose de d'institutions
d'enseignement tout à fait remarquable
nos grandes écoles non non feinte ou
qu'ils n'ont rien à envier à nos grandes
écoles c'est très peu connu et le nombre
de boursiers français en inde comme le
nombre de boursiers ou d'étudiant ou des
changes indien en france sont
extrêmement faibles
il faut absolument développer cela il ya
beaucoup de partenariats qui sont signés
entre plein d'écoles en france et plein
d'école en inde
et c'est toujours des principes et on
n'arrive jamais ou très rarement à
passer au concret et on a besoin de
passer au concret et puis dernier point
je crois qu'on doit réellement aider
l'inde à à s'ouvrir la ne s'ouvre pas
assez nous pouvons nous avons des
valeurs démocratiques qu'on partage
ensemble on a un goût pour la culture
c'est une culture différente mais un
goût pour la culture extrêmement
développé nos nos valeurs démocratiques
je le disais sont les mêmes ou en tout
cas proche et donc nous devons aider
l'inde à s'ouvrir
nous devons aider l'inde aussi à ceux
des normalisée c'est un pays extrêmement
complexe sur le plan administratif elle
est absolument à la fois corruption très
forte et à la fois une administration
extrêmement puissante qui parvient
quasiment à geler les projets dans tous
les sens nous savons ce que c'est que
trop d'administration donc nous pouvons
peut-être aider l'inde à réduire son
niveau d'administration et dernier point
on doit les aider l'inde sur le plan
international le g20 est aujourd'hui en
panne en panne totale
l'inde doit pouvoir jouer un rôle dans
la décrispation du g20 dans le fait que
le g20 représente à nouveau une forme de
gouvernance mondiale et puis dernier
point et nicolas sarkozy l'avait évoqué
notamment avec l'arena maudit l'inde
doit disposer d'un siège permanent au
conseil de sécurité des nations unies
yahya c'est impossible qu'un pays de
cette taille avec les enjeux qu'il y a
les conflits d'ailleurs autour de l'un
de ses relations complexes que la chine
ses relations extrêmement complexe et
historique avec le pakistan
tout cela doit amener à siéger
au conseil de sécurité des nations unies
voilà quelques mouches sur note sur ce
point était très important que la merci
beaucoup pour cet éclairage là encore
très utile et est très juste ce pays
c'est sous le général de gaulle quand
nous avons nous français des coûts vers
l'inde et on a puissamment aidé ce pays
s moderniser tout le programme spatial
indien
il est le produit une coopération avec
la france tout le programme nucléaire
indien
elle produit d'une coopération avec la
france les premières usines d'armement
en inde
je pense aux jaguars par exemple été
résultat trois passions que la france
ensuite il ya une grande période de vide
et c'est avec nicolas sarkozy quand il a
décidé que l'inde serait un partenaire
stratégique qu'on a redémarré un
partenariat stratégique mais qui a du
mal à décoller parce qu'on a peu c'est
un marché très difficile il faut des
années et des années négociations pour
aboutir à un accord
et même s'il ya de grande
complémentarité je pense aux réseaux de
transport par exemple qu'il disait ou
l'agriculture
il faut que les entreprises acceptent
d'investir longtemps nos problèmes que
nous avons dans notre pays
d'abord c'est qu'on a un tissu de pme
insuffisant et que deuxièmement les
grands groupes
quand c'est trop difficile peuvent être
un peu frileux mais tu as complètement l
on dira que c'est stratégique pour notre
avenir et qu'il faudra et accorder une
grande priorité
il nous reste 15 minutes et deux
orateurs moi je suis très content on est
dans les temps
alors on va dire un mot des autres
grands qui émergent en amérique du sud
grâce à pascal droz qui connaît très
bien c'est un des rares experts français
de l'amérique du sud
vous l'avez qu il a longtemps été ici au
parti mais aussi été dans le privé chez
alstom aujourd'hui hélas devenu general
electric j'ai honte de le dire
et puis nous terminerons pas une vision
est que le mic justement avec philippe
cochet
monsieur draw merci pierre
l'amérique latine dans le sujet qui nous
intéresse une nouvelle puissance ou les
ambitions depuis ces dernières années
elle a beaucoup changé
les passes et rappelez vous de cette
décennie perdue les années 80 avec une
hyperinflation 10000 % d'inflation des
guerres les guerres civiles à une
décennie qui a été celle de l'espoir les
années 90 le retour au pouvoir civil le
développement économique et sept
décennies a conduit à la mise en plis
qu'à sion en application de modèle
économique dans les années 2000 qui nous
conduisent aujourd'hui à la croisée des
chemins avec l'amérique latine et le
change
elle a profondément changé avec
cependant des fondamentaux qui peuvent
encore ses ambitions et sa
projection dans les relations
internationales
l'amérique latine en effet les diverses
et mini à la fois 33 pays 525 millions
cinq cent trente millions d'habitants
78% d'ailleurs de la population active
américaine qui vit dans des zones
urbaines ce qui constitue d'ailleurs
deschamps pour nous économique
formidable en termes de prospection de
marchés et pour autant cette amérique
latine là cet handicap de d'essayer de
se construire sur des individualités
étatique c'est vrai qu'il ya des
économies qui pèsent le mexique
c'est la quatorzième économie du monde
aujourd'hui le brésil et le brésil
traverse une crise extrêmement profonde
mais qui sera peut-être une chance pour
lui et qui est encore là
septième huitième économie mondiale et
pour autant ses individualités je pense
évidemment à l'argentine le chili
toute la façade du pacifique elle essaie
malgré tout qu'un cas de construire des
unités régionales
le mexique lui il se vit en puissance
régionale avec l'amérique centrale
depuis des décennies mais les
centraméricains ben ils regardent aussi
ailleurs il regarde vers l'asie bien
évidemment et il regarde dans cette
recherche d'unité vers des entités
régionales qui se sont construites
durant ces dernières années je pense
notamment à l'alba et je reviendrai sur
ce point avec un élément fondamental
cr année en profond de crise aujourd'hui
qui est le venezuela la façade du
pacifique et vail a construit dans cette
recherche d'unité
l'alliance du pacifique c'est trois
quatre dernières années le mexique la
colombie le pérou le chili ce sont des
pays qui avance agressif qui ont un taux
de croissance important le pérou à un
taux de croissance qui alternent au fil
des années entre 4 et 5% la colombie
tout autant évidemment vous avez sur le
reste du continent le mercosur qui
consomment malgré tout 80% du commerce
régional sud américain et le chili qui
regarde à la fois vers le pacifique
l'asie et vers ses partenaires
économiques régionaux alors c'est vrai
que l'amérique latine elle souffre de ce
contraste un contraste entre eux ces
individualités tatic et ça c'est
important
chacun ayant une ambition le mexique
pèse dans des négociations
multilatérales
nous ambassadeurs le savent bien mais le
mexique essayé de peser aux nations
unies au sein du g20 dans les
négociations sur le climat le brésil
bien évidemment sont des pays qui essaie
d'ailleurs d'avoir une ambition en
matière de nucléaire civil
je rappelle le partenariat stratégique
qui avait été établi sous la présidence
de nicolas sarkozy avec le brésil mais
le mexique a aussi une ambition en
matière de nucléaire civil
je vous rappelle que l'amérique latine
depuis 68 et la signature du traité de
tlatelolco est une zone de non
prolifération nucléaire et en fait
totalement désarmé sur le plan du
nucléaire et pour autant donc cette
amérique latine abel est à la croisée
des chemins aujourd'hui oui elle est à
la croisée des chemins
croisée des chemins sur le plan
économique il y à des majors il ya de
grands groupes économiques qui pèsent au
mexique
cemex ica au brésil
et ce groupe fait la une au brésil mais
très présent en amérique latine au de
brecht par exemple qui est un partenaire
de groupes industriels français pour
entrer sur le continent et donc pour
autant et bien il ya sept chemins de
cette croisée des chemins
sur le plan également politique avec
notamment autour du nouveau président
argentin mauricio macri la recherche
d'un ensemble nouveau alternatif à
l'alba l'alba qui ce modèle construit
par le venezuela et le brésil pour être
le pendant d'une approche
libre
fondée sur le libre échange commercial
sur le continent alors la france
la france elle a une bonne image
ceci étant ça décolle pas la france
reste sur le plan économique à des
niveaux des changes économique faible 1
2 3% mais guère plus
alors même que la culture nous rapproche
fondamentalement que nous avons de bons
groupes
mais des groupes qui pâtissent notamment
du coût de leurs produits nous ne nous
en souffrons beaucoup
en amérique latine qui elle dans cette
recherche de nouvelles ambitions s'ouvre
à de nouveaux partenaires la turquie
erdogan était en visite officielle au
chili en équateur au pérou il y a deux
mois j'étais présent j'ai pu voir
l'agressivité des chefs d'entreprises
turques dans les infra dans les services
est évidemment la chine la chine et
devant les états unis en termes d'
échanges économiques avec notamment le
brésil donc autant de partenaires
nouveaux qui nous oblige être bon à
avoir les bons prix et avoir une vision
alors même que le redéploiement
diplomatiques et consulaires se réduit
même en amérique latine merci merci
beaucoup pascal encore une fois bravo
pour cette très bonne analyse
quant au développement turquie le voit
aussi en afrique de façon spectaculaire
turkish airlines est ouverte 30 ligne
avec l'afrique ces deux dernières années
il ya une percée très forte et turcs et
chinois sur ces continents et nous nous
sommes en rab et le impôts le chiffre de
1% sont exactes c'est un d un des soucis
majeurs qu'on doit avoir
dernier orateur de cette matinée
philippe cochet député du rhône qui va
nous donner un petit coup d'éclairage
sur la gouvernance mondiale sous plan
économique et je remercie de rester dans
le créneau pardon 17 minutes bien merci
merci beaucoup pierre
tout d'abord je crois que ça va tout à
fait en complément de ce qui vient
d'être évoquée sur les différents
continents
il ya tout d'abord le monde d'hier et le
monde d'aujourd'hui
je crois qu'un certain nombre
d'institutions qui existent notamment
l'onu donc a été créée suite bien sûr au
désastre de la deuxième guerre mondiale
où ce sont finalement les vainqueurs de
cette guerre qui ont pris les manettes
pour organiser tout ceci est valable il
ya 71 ans maintenant aujourd'hui comme
ça a été évoqué tout à l'heure il est
nécessaire tout d'abord d'intégrer
notamment au niveau du conseil de
sécurité
d'autres puissances ont parlé de la
chine je pense qu'on peut parler du
brésil bien sûr de l'allemagne pour que
celui ci puisse être beaucoup plus
représentatif par rapport à ce qu'il est
aujourd'hui
par ailleurs de nouvelles puissances ont
émergé et dans ce contexte là il est
évident et comme ça a été indiqué
donc tout à l'heure en particulier au
niveau de l'afrique il est nécessaire
que l'afrique soit présente que le monde
arabe soit présent parce que les uns et
les autres doivent pouvoir travailler
ensemble car c'est ensemble qu'ils
pourront notamment permettre une
meilleure régulation au niveau
international alors tout à l'heure nous
avons évoqué le g20
le g20 a eu un moment très fort
notamment en 2010 2011 quand le
président de la république française à
l'époque nicolas sarkozy en a pris la
tête car d'entrée
pardon il a même inventé tout à fait sûr
sur la démarche mais au-delà de ça il
avait une volonté notamment de faire
évoluer cette institution pour que celle
ci puisse aller beaucoup plus loin
la mondialisation est une belle et bonne
chose
celle ci sera d'autant plus accepter
acceptable que la richesse pourra être
partagée que des différences pourront
être comblés et enfin qu'il y à un
accompagnement au niveau de la gestion
de celle-ci et dans cette approche là
malheureusement depuis donc la
présidence de nicolas sarkozy
il n'y a eu aucun effort de la part du
gouvernement français du président de la
république en l'occurrence car les
choses n'ont pas bougé
et si je prends un sujet qui touche
notamment
le fmi qui a un rôle bien sûr
considérables et qui peut peser sur
l'évolution d'un certain nombre
d'économies comme ça a été évoqué tout à
l'heure par madame au niveau de la chine
la banque mondiale et le fmi ne
répondent pas aujourd'hui un certain
nombre de demandes donc eh bien quand on
trouve pas on crée et ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que les institutions
aujourd'hui existantes s'affaiblissent
s'auto affaiblissent du fait de leur
incapacité à s'adapter à la réalité ou
aujourd'hui nécessaire et tout ça a une
conséquence bien évidemment évidente
c'est que face à des noms régulateur eh
bien il ya des éléments périphériques
qui peuvent se passer notamment une
dérégulation de ce que nous
souhaiterions faire notamment au niveau
du commerce international il faut savoir
qu'aujourd'hui notre pays parce que
lorsqu'on parle notamment des relations
extérieures on parle souvent des droits
de l'homme on parle souvent de culture
et moi je vous parle est un petit peu
d'économie et de business
je sais que c'est parfois un mot qui
pose problème et je parle sous la
responsabilité de l'ancien ministre du
commerce extérieur qui a connu cette
implication
c'est à dire que la france aujourd'hui
nous avons quand même 45 milliards
d'euros de déficit annuel au niveau de
notre balance commerciale
nous avons aujourd'hui un champ la
france et ça a été évoqué dans les
différentes d'un par les différents
orateurs qui se sont exprimés à des
opportunités extraordinaires
simplement il faut qu'à un moment ou un
autre nous puissions être en capacité de
nous battre à armes égales
et quand on voit en particulier et
pierre lellouche l'évoqué tout à l'heure
sur notamment un certain nombre de
décisions supranationale qui s'imposent
à notre pays je pense aux états unis et
bien
la mondialisation elle est caviardé donc
dans cette approche là il est
indispensable de reprendre le leadership
et je pense que le g20 peut vraiment
être un lieu qui permet non seulement
d'améliorer et de faciliter le commerce
international deuxièmement de permettre
à tout le monde de bénéficier de cette
richesse comme ça est évoquée tant au
niveau de la démographie qu'au niveau de
la progression aujourd'hui des économies
il faut qu'à un moment ou un autre il y
ait des régulateurs ont peut-être
libéraux totalement au niveau de la
conception économique mais un moment ou
un autre pour gérer la situation
internationale
il est nécessaire d'avoir des entités
qui soit respectable et respecté il ya
soixante dix ans un certain nombre
d'entités ont été créés aujourd'hui
elles doivent se renouveler
nous avons un certain nombre de
propositions et je crois que ça fera
partie bien sûr du rôle des républicains
de proposer des choses dans ce sens là
je vous remercie beaucoup au filet merci
ben écoutez nous voici au terme de cette
deuxième table on jouerait que vous
applaudissez à nouveau nos intervenants
qui en fait réussi le tour de force en
quelques minutes chacun de vous donner
vraiment un éclairage fort intéressant
de ce qui se passe dans le monde qui
nous entoure et qui pose le problème de
notre futur diplomatie je les remercie
beaucoup